bonjour bonjour
et bien aujourd'hui knight et vous a
proposé un cassoulet un cassoulet de son
village un cassoulet de rion des landes
alors d'ajouter qu est ce que vous
mettez dans le cassoulet quand vous êtes
arrivé quand on fait du cassoulet chez
nous en met deux bonnes choses alors on
met tout d'abord dans la ventrèche mais
des haricots des tomates fraîches des
coûts de canard confit des quads des
saucisses détendu lauriers de l'oignon
de l'échalote de live du sel et du
poivre et notre conflit alors rappelez
nous confie ce que c'est aux fonctions
des morceaux de canard que vous avez
cuit dans la grève et les faits dans un
gros pot en verre comme celui là afin de
pouvoir les utiliser hors saison quand
on veut qu'elle avait préparé un petit
instrument bizarre non qui est à neutre
à vendre et vous aussi le cocu rohff
l'assaut terrestre vient de chez nous
aussi
sa sert a flambé cette sensationnelle
alors vous n'aviez déjà montré mais je
crois que maintenant il ya un artisan
qui peut en fabriquer bien sûr et c'est
très recherché parce qu'on ne fait pas
ça on n'en n'auront à chaque fois il
faut le commander le fabriquer c'est la
tête devant soi même elle en a trouvé un
système pour le faire des montages bien
où ils permettent de transporter puis
forlan comme ça on présente pour le
mettre en vente leur portée où on veut
et c'est mon incombera de toute façon
c'est beaucoup plus facile alors ce
concurrent nous verrons bien à quoi il
sert tout à l'heure mais pour le moment
je crois que vous avez l'intention de le
mettre dans la cheminée avant d'être
acheminés pour ses serviteurs
parce qu'il faut qu'ils chauffent tres
tres tres rouge mais ma blonde et il
faut qu'ils chauffent à blanc alors
voilà on va le mettre dans la slam comme
ceux ci et on va les questions bobillier
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
il ya 21 ans continue notre cassoulet
c'est à dire on va prendre des ricoh
qu'on va mettre dans l'autre bouillonne
dans d'autres eaux qui est bouillante
pour la brenaz la raison
maïté à la saison on aurait pris des
haricots frais mais nous ne sommes pas
dans la saison des haricots frais donc
on les a fait trembler toute la nuit
suivante
et alors vous les laitiers dans ce cas
là le bouillon à l'eau bouillante parce
qu'ils sont trompés parce qu'ils ont
trempé toute la nuit il y en a c'est est
ce que vous allez passer maintenant ou
pas il serait très peu très peu pour la
bonne raison que j'avais tout ce qu'on
va y mettre
il faut un routeur prix fort n'y pas
assez salée rajouter que le contraire on
va couvrir et on va faire un dollar dont
bon on s'y met à 2
les couper en lui tenant là c'est bien
on va pousser nos saucisses mme et on
coupe les lardons à peu faire là que je
dois faire avec césar dont on va les
faire si on va les faire frire quand on
entre dans la poêle vous prenez votre
cru dans le jus alors est ce que vous
mettez un peu de graisse dans le fond de
la pole ou pas du tout mais bien sûr
vous le faites pendant que je coupe
soyez au besoin de se mettre vite règle
c'est pas la peine bon ben ça y est la c
coupé
voilà je vais vous les importez pour
vous et votre graisse là bas nous de
cuir et oui ça suffit je suis pas ce
qu'il va faire un petit peu de gras
quand même alors cela il est déjà un
petit peu poivrez
la rave ou là ce sont cette fois bien
figé d'assaisonner déjà vous les a pas
voilà la grèce est assez chaude ça va
enfin ça y est ça va quand même la très
bien ils vont accueillir 1 va commencer
à couper les oignons pendant ce temps
très bien alors je vous laisse le
concernant on va découper grossièrement
quand même oui parce que ça on les fera
cuire après les prévenir d'autres aussi
oui en lamelles oui parce que là yvan à
foz las moulias ça ils ont faim et
charlotte aussi où seulement mettre une
échalote si ça fait pour le goût un
petit peu que ça oui et on va écraser
notre union la moitié des oignons voyons
maintenant comment on va ne m'étais pas
mal quand même pris fonction du goût à
l'oignon et demi vous avez aimé les
voilà ça commence à la résille et vous
voulez grêlé revenir ici vous voulez
tellement pendant que vous coupez ça je
vais me couper aussi l'aïe les lie ça va
ça va ça va aller où enfin tout juste
bon alors là il ya les i
il écrase et aussi en écrasant pareil là
et vous le dégermer vous l'écran des
rayures et vous l'ajoutez avec les
lardons ou je vais enlever les lardons
en descendeur dont l'épreuve yolande
mariette vous me dites les enlève c'est
bon vous écraser à la main pourquoi
est-ce que vous écrire à la main parce
que j'ai rien sous la mer dont on peut
faire n'importe quoi voulez le hachoir
c'est ben oui mais je peux faire la même
et pourquoi est ce que vous les décrivez
de jus que le chu reste voilà donc oui
je vais les oeuvres oui je l'aimais trop
du keirin on était là à tous les midis
riblon 8e bien sûr bien sûr pour vous
les jolies mais dans la 80 sans le juger
oui notre plus dur est adoré un tout
petit peu plus mais on voit tous mais
bien sûr bien sûr et à ses deux petits
fours grotte vous allez mettre les gaz à
fond et au delà je recouvre
voilà donc ça fond qu'est ce qu'on fait
on s'occupe des soucis on va maintenant
dans son 6e sur les guildes acheminés
c'est ça la différence du cassoulet à
pascal le cunff inédit de castelnaudary
au met office de réduire la saucisse
dedans quand c'est à dire car les
haricots sont pratiquement cuit en mai
que mai la société de da et là encore on
va aimer faire comme apte et le thym et
le laurier
donc on a oublié je voulais pas avant de
mettre les saucisses
non on va là coupé et vous rajouterez
vos oignons après être la barre on
apportera non mais maintenant c'est fait
dans la plus grande importance à la
normale avant je n'avais été vaillante
il aurait fallu apple et la tomate et
aux cantons pauvres 7 po et oui oui bah
on sait bien que je voulais l'appeler on
l'a fait tremper à l'eau bouillante et
la bouche de la culture la presse n'est
pas dramatique en voilà mais très bien
la seule quand même beaucoup mieux que
je pouvais la battre pour gagner un
petit peu de couleurs un peu de couleur
et puis beaucoup quand même mais bon je
vous passe le thym le laurier
coupez oui en petits morceaux une seule
suffira de laurier oui oui oui parce que
des lauriers sa part d'autant plus
depuis l'avenue laurier disais voilà
ajoute très bien un peu de thym sur la
lys et je roule pas de branche voilà on
va remuer un petit peu notre pognon il
faut encore des soucis
oui là on va couper nos saucisson va
couvrir sa part des colonies andorre on
va découper parce qu'elles sont pas
coupés je pense elles sont au kilomètre
ça a été un bon nombre et qu'on aime
pour cette quantité a reconnu il faut -
il ose aussi ce pour chacun maintenant
on va quitter ses saucisses avec une
fonction avec une fourchette
oumma parti pour pas qu'elle s'éclate
sur la braise éclatera au moins sur la
bresse
voilà pour éviter qu'elles se fondent
dans tous les sens oui elles vont perdre
un peu de graisse elle va faire un peu
de graisse avons pas éclaté voilà et on
va les mettre à les lire oui ce dont on
insiste éric est très très bien il
suffit de pouvoir la voie là et là ça
cuit ça permet de cuire hauteur et
depuis le très bien très bien on va les
laisser sur la bresse et pendant ce
temps va retrouver un petit peu ce qu'on
a à faire il en tout cas sous les halles
aux oignons ont bougé un peu tirés mais
avec un bon j'ai un petit peu mais ils
sont bien on va les mettre maison de
koudougou
alors on va les mettre dans notre
cassoulet là on sent peu bronzé il faut
arrêter ça devient un peu moins de
fautes et bien oui mais ça fait rien
c'est comme ça la peau est ensuite
froide on avait dit que vous alliez
ajouter encore au tube alors rajouter no
koi no no quan et qui ont fui dans le
confit c'est pas pareil c'est pas la
quad accrue et voilà la différence est
alors là elle a laissé un petit peu de
gras et puis des coups de canne à
recomposer la pardon pour que les couper
en deux avec les un choix
grand choix et puis ça y est et on va
les mettre dans l'autre confie sa part
dans les mauvais goût non alors ça c'est
le temps de bouillir oui contrairement
aux confits qu'on va y rajouter après on
va la mettre au dernier moment
pourvu que ça ça donne déjà le goût du
confit et ça sera juste pour découvrir
qu'ils allaient nous montrez vous allez
me montrer ce que vous faites avec la
donc vous avez mis les couilles lequan
et vous fermez là m'a remis pour en
faire continuer la cuisson très bien qui
dure déjà depuis un bon moment et alors
le sommet proprement dit il dans ce pot
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on va le faire
griller
on va le faire griller on va le mettre
dans cette toile on va allumer le feu
oui on va la mettre dans cette étoile
on va le faire revenir là où bien à
dégraisser de faire dorer un peu
attention ce faire vous l'avez fait
quand il ya des mois qu'il est nous sont
très longtemps bien sûr ça conserve à
l'envolée m voilà on va le prendre
on va mettre la peau du côté de la poêle
pour que ce soit la peau qui dort parce
que ça c'est rien d'un concept et voilà
alors là vous mettez une cuisse par
personne oui ça dépend combien vous êtes
m'a dit et moi qu'il n'y a pas personne
une hausse aussi une belle prise comme
ça les abreuvant de la line dance et à
mal c'est le repas complet voilà et on
va laisser bien dorées ceux-ci kan
décorera après avec nos saucisses et
saucissons bien grillé rivières jeudi on
va les passer au cocuron on va les
passer au concurrent notre petit
appareil
je prends gras de jambon je mets dans
cet appareil ou qui ça et voilà
et on les a posés vers le grave avant
d'intégrer à vendre et va donner un bon
petit bout de jambon
parce que ça c'est notre bon jambon de
chez nous
pareil voilà les salles arrangements la
différence du cassoulet le rayon des
langues
et oui on s'applique toujours on met
toujours un petit plus toute manière ça
ne bougera que l'autre parce que les
soucis c'est un gratte-ciel cuisse dont
le oui et le conflit vous allez voir
votre grille aussi voilà dès que le
concurrent fini de brûler je vous
apporter le flat bon parce que oui me
paraît tout à fait à point voilà vers la
sortie
voilà alors je vous donne la fourchette
ne vous brûlez pas sur d'autres non et
on va les présenter à prix hélas est
prêt à manger et ça ne rentrent pas dans
la sauce de l'autre question c'est pour
ça qu'il était le plus léger le graët
parrish quand même un peu plus léger et
cuisses de confie son superbe elles sont
de réels sont appétissantes
alors on a tous fini non pas pourquoi on
va finir entre petits secrets vous allez
le voir on va prendre une cuillère de
graisse de canard bien sûr c'était les
petits secrets des grands mères
autrefois et on va y mettre ses tailles
qu'on a écrasé pile est très très saint
louis on ne mélange dans la grèce et on
est au milieu de notre casserole est on
venu
[Musique]
dernier petit malaise voilà sans l'air
derrière mais mon dieu que ça arrange
tout ça arrange tout voilà et maintenant
vas y mettre on va remettre tout alors
là qu'on aime on voit aux nanos kuen on
va les manger
bien sûr ça c'est non mais bien sur les
coups des coups de canard fumé et puis
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a là encore on en
est un beau super dollars dont il a loué
tout ça est alors qu'est-ce qu'on ajoute
alors maintenant on va ajouter l'eau
confie quand vous allez simplement posé
de foncer dessus parce que du moment
qu'il ya le coût qui a donné le goût
bien sûr on n'a pas besoin de faire
tremper alors formé notre corps fille
voilà là c'est un cas isolé pour trois
personnes
mammeri saoudite - chez vous on a volé
betty quand même bien sûr le fils le
mari et vous et ça y est ça vous met en
forme ça n'arrivera alors ensuite les
saucisses également pour trois personnes
pour personne on va mettre tous les cas
une quatrième pour la forme
mal rasé dans les langues c'est pas trop
mal à voir s'il n'y a pas au luxe
voilà et bien et que ça vous pouvez
essayer et je vous conseille d'essayer
parce que c'est bon et à bientôt
elle va voir
[Musique]